bienvenidos al vídeo de máximo común
divisor o máximo factor común pero
aclaremos las ideas digamos que alguien
te pide que calcule es el máximo común
divisor de 12 y 8 o el máximo factor
común de 12 y 8 en realidad te están
pidiendo la misma cosa cuando hablamos
de divisores hablamos de números que
dividen a otros y cuando hablamos de
factores también son números que dividen
a otros y que es lo que tengo que hacer
bueno con lo que tengo que hacer es
encontrar los factores de cada uno de
estos números veamos cuáles son los
factores de 12 bueno de 12 tenemos al 1
tenemos al 2 tenemos al 3 al 4 bueno el
5 no están
tenemos el 6 y tenemos al 2
y para el 8 tenemos al 1 tenemos al 2 el
3 no está el 4 siesta y el 5 tampoco
tenemos hasta él
ahora tenemos que identificar qué
factores son comunes por ejemplo primero
tenemos alumno pero no todos los números
enteros tienen como factor el 1
entonces el 1 no tiene nada de especial
el 2 también es común
luego tenemos al 4 y bien ahora de lo
que se trata no es identificar cualquier
factor sino el mayor de ellos el máximo
de ellos y entonces en este caso lo que
podemos observar es que el máximo de los
comunes es el número 4 por lo que el
máximo común divisor de 12 y 8 es igual
a 4
y el máximo factor común
12 y 8 es igual a 4 hagamos más ejemplos
bien ahora nos piden calcular el máximo
común divisor de 25 y 20 entonces
volvemos a hacer lo mismo vamos a ver
los factores de cada uno de ellos
entonces para el 25 tenemos el uno
tenemos el 5 y tenemos el 25 este es un
caso muy interesante de un número que
tiene un número de factores impar y
bueno luego yo te invito a que pienses
en este caso especial porque estos son
los factores bueno ahora vamos con el 20
el 20 tiene como factores al uno tiene
dos tiene al 4 en el 5 tiene el 10 y al
y bien ahora observemos cuáles son
comunes bueno el 1 que ya ya lo habíamos
dicho
todos los números enteros tienen alguno
como factor y luego pues nada más está
el 5
entonces el máximo común divisor de 25
y 20 es igual a 5 perfecto
hagamos un ejemplo más
ahora vamos a calcular el máximo factor
común de 5 y 12
muy bien entonces procedemos igual del 5
quiénes son sus factores pues tenemos al
1 y al 5 claro en este caso 5 es un
número primo y por definición un número
primo sólo tiene como factores al 1 y
asimismo ahora vamos con el 12
el 12 tiene como factores al 1 2 3 4 y
también tiene al 6 y también pues el 12
y este es un caso muy interesante porque
el factor común solo es el 1
entonces el máximo factor común de 5 y
12 es igual a 1
en matemáticas cuando dos números tienen
como máximo factor común alumno les
decimos primos relativos bueno no trató
de confundirte con nada sino simplemente
extender los conceptos con los que
estamos trabajando
hagamos un ejemplo más ahora vamos a ver
cuál es el máximo común divisor de 6 y
12 muy bien entonces del 6 volvemos a
proceder igual sus factores son el 1 el
2 y 3 y el 6 y del 12 tenemos al 1
2 al 3 al 4 al 6 y el 12 y entonces
podemos observar que en este caso el
máximo común divisor el factor más
grande que comparten es el número 6 o
sea el máximo común divisor de 6 y 12 es
igual a 6 claro en este caso también es
simpático coincide que el máximo común
divisor es uno de los números que este
que tenemos en nuestro ejemplo y bueno
el 6 pues cabe perfectamente dos veces
entonces en fin
voy a hacer más vídeos con más ejemplos
y seguiremos trabajando estos conceptos
y por lo pronto eso es todo